And so for this topic, I really
want to talk about the
different APIs and
authentication options you
have within your applications
as well as authorization.
For the first part, I have
a username and password.
How do I authorize
that person?
Secondly, how do we protect two
different groups of people
in your application?
As part of that, though, I also
want to talk on how you
would access other APIs
and use important
protocols such as OAuth.
And finally, how you would offer
your application as an
OAuth provider and actually let
Google take care of that
OAuth handshake for you.
The first step, authentication
options.
There's really two different
options you have.
We have built-in support
leveraging Google Apps
accounts, or even the OpenID
through Federation.
What you do is say, I want my
application to be restricted
to anybody that has
a Google account.
And that could be Gmail,
or it could be any
Google Enterprise customer.
You can also restrict
your application to
one Google App domain.
Although that's supported, I'd
recommend against doing that.
It's much better to handle
that in your code.
Then, of course, if you don't
want to use one of these
built-in operations, you
have custom code.
You can do whatever you
want inside your app
to authorize people.
For the built-in authentication,
this is all
configured when you first
create your application.
By default, it will list as open
to all Google accounts.
You can also restrict to
a single domain name.
But if you do that, it's
restricted to a single domain.
And most enterprises have
more than one domain.
I know of some that have at
least 60 different domains.
You have
contractors@mycompany.com or
externals@mycompany.com.
And if you do that,
you could only
restrict this to one domain.
So you're going to lose out
on a lot of people in your
application.
It's therefore much better to
leave it open to all Google
accounts and then restrict it
within your application.
We also offer an OpenID provider
that's experimental.
And what this allows you to do
is you can accept a Facebook
account or a Yahoo account
or any other OpenID
provider that we accept.
You can, of course, also
provide your own
OpenID using just code.
But we provide a library that
makes it a little bit easier
to consume.
Now, if you do specify restrict
to a single Google
Apps domain, that can't be
changed by yourself through
the console.
You have to open a support
ticket which, of course, you
need a premier account to do.
So if you ever have to change
that in the future, you'd have
to reach out to us to
help you with that.
If you do use the Google
accounts authentication, the
very first time that a user is
being asked to provide their
identity to your application,
they're
prompted with this screen.
In summary, the screen is
notifying the user that we're
going to give this application
your email address and ask
whether they're OK with that.
That's all it's asking.
There's nothing else.
And you can't access any other
data for that user other than
just their email address.
And it will remember it for
30 days if they elect it.
Once they do this, then they're
automatically entered
into your application and
they're good to go.
Redo.
Once they do this, then they're
entered automatically
into your application.
And you're good to go.
You can see who the user email
address is and change your
application's behavior
based on that.
Something to point out, though,
is that you don't
actually have the ability
to change this screen.
This is provided from Google
so that we can take a step
back and say, look
what's going on.
And you can't hide it in some
other login screen.
When you're restricted to a
single Google Apps domain, it
doesn't actually prompt the user
for authorization because
it assumes that this is for
only one Google domain.
So it probably has only
been hosted by
the enterprise customer.
And it doesn't make sense
to prompt for the only
application.
We're working on ways to make
it more seamless for
enterprise customers.
But this is what
you have today.
Some people may say, well, I
don't like having my users
prompted because it doesn't make
sense to log in to my own
internal application.
And we'd argue that it actually
does because they
could run into the screen across
the board anywhere.
And there's a lot of
apps out there.
So it's a good opportunity to
educate your users on what the
expectations are and make sure
they're aware of what's
happening when they click
on an Accept button.
Within your application, when
you want to restrict it, if
you specify just open to all
Google Apps accounts, by
default it doesn't actually
prompt the users to log in.
And it won't give your
email address.
You actually have to tell your
application that this section
is protected and require
a login.
You can do that two ways.
One is through configuration
files.
And I vote Java, web.xml,
or a Python app.yaml.
And you could also
do this in code.
You could actually call
an API that says, is
this user logged in?
And then, redirect them to the
appropriate login page.
For this, what you see is
a pattern with the URL.
And then, we have a role name.
You have one of two options
setting the role name.
An asterisk, in Java, which
means that it didn't need to
be logged in.
It doesn't matter which role, or
it just simply says, log in
as required for Python.
Or you can mention
the role admin.
This is a built in rule that we
use at Google meaning they
are listed as somebody that
you've already delegated
access to on your App
Engine project.
So that viewer--
a developer, an owner--
if they're listed as one of
those members in your console,
they're going to be treated as
admin user inside of your
application.
So it's very easy to have an
admin interface without having
to build your own access
control inside your
application.
One limitation is that you can
currently have 10 developers
working on an application
at a single time.
If you have a Premier account,
you can add more if you open a
support ticket.
And you have to tell us every
single person you want to add,
and there's going to be
lead time for that.
However, if you're going to
develop an admin section that
needs more than 10 users or
has a lot of user changes,
it's probably best just to build
your own mechanism into
your application.
But it's very simple.
This is a great way to do it.
Or the super-admin type
of interface.
It's a very convenient way to
build into the infrastructure.
If you do decide not to use the
built-in Google accounts
authentication, then you can
develop anything you want to
control access.
In fact, there's no problem if
you want to integrate with
your own enterprise
single sign-in.
The only constraint is
currently, we only allow
outbound connections from App
Engine on port 480 and 443 so
that if you want to access your
single sign-on server
over some background
channel, you must
connect on those ports.
Obviously, a lot of people use
username and passwords.
But if you're storing that in
the data storage, use good
common sense and encrypt that.
Or do something to make
it a little harder for
people to get to.
And if you go through your own
custom route, you would create
your application as open
to all Google accounts.
And you just wouldn't tell your
application to restrict
access at any point.
You just build that into
your code yourself.
We provide a user API.
And what this allows you
to do, once someone's
authenticated, you can get
their nickname and their
email, which is usually
the same thing.
They have slightly different
variations if it's a Federated
identity or not.
You also have the user ID, the
Federated identity, and
Federated provider.
And this would tell you, for
example, that they're coming
from Yahoo and what the Yahoo
ID is for their Federated
identity and provider.
For the user ID, it's
an identifier in our
infrastructure.
And in fact, a user's email
address could change over
time, especially with Google
Apps customers.
They could change that
email address.
Maybe they get married
or something changes.
In this way, if you want to use
a unique identifier for
that user, it might be safer
to rely on that, user ID,
rather than an email address.
As well as the basic figuring
out who the user is, you have
a few functions.
One of them is to create a login
URL that would redirect
that user to the appropriate
login.
If they're already logged in,
then it would just direct them
to that page that says, allow
this application to see our
email address.
You can also get that current
user in the function as well
as this current user
as an admin.
Finally, you have an environment
variable named
AUTH_DOMAIN telling you
what your application
is restricted to.
If it's open to all Google
accounts, it would be gmail.com.
If the users are Google Apps
customers and they've already
integrated single sign-on with
the Google Apps environment,
then you get to take
advantage of that.
It will detect that they have
single sign-on, and it will
redirect them to the single
sign-on server and
automatically authenticate them
if they already have an
active session.
Therefore, the end user
experience would be just the
prompt of, do you want to allow
the application to get
your email address?
And then, they're in.
They don't actually have to
provide their username.
And they're never presented
with a Google
brand and login page.
It's all the single
sign-on system.
Here's a couple of examples
of the user API.
In Java, it's very simple.
There's a factory to get
the user service.
And then, if that user's null,
then they're not logged in.
And you could redirect them
to the login user.
Or likewise, if the user service
is an admin user, it
says true or false.
So it's very simple
to do this.
To use this inside of your code,
adding perhaps a section
of code or some other function
that you only want to allow
admin users to trigger.
In Python, it's very similar.
Here, I show a little bit more
code where you'd actually use
the create login URL method.
When you create the login URL,
you just tell the URL that
they would be redirected to on
your application after they
get authenticated.
Now, the more complicated
topic is authorization.
There are entire books and
classes discussing the
different authorization
methods.
However, we'll touch only
on some important ones.
I'm going to first provide a
high-level overview and break
it into two topics.
One is the internal access
control within your
application.
The second one is delegation,
discussing how you'd either
access an external third party,
whether it be Google or
some other entity, to access a
user's data without requiring
the user's name and password,
as well as access a data
service that you want to
provide so that your
application can consume that.
If you don't want to provide a
username and password for that
user to log into your
application, that's where the
OAuth dance comes in.
And we'll discuss that
a little bit later.
First one, though, is internal
access control.
You'll have the admin role,
which we've already discussed.
You also can leverage Google
Apps groups, enterprise
customers that already have
Google Apps synchronized with
Active Directory.
Adding a user to this group will
automatically grant them
access to the application.
It's very seamless
and very nice.
In your code, you would just
use the provisioning API.
This is a GData API.
And look up this user, checking
whether their email
address is this group.
It simply returns
true or false.
There's some overhead on that.
So you'd want to cache
the results.
But it's just a fairly
simple thing to do.
And of course, there's nothing
that prevents you from
creating your own list of roles
and attaching to users
and using that as a mechanism to
figure out who can do what
inside your application.
There are also a lot of
commercial products that are
single sign-on that do a
lot of authorization.
They seem great on
the surface.
But a lot of times, they're
challenging to integrate with
your application.
So sometimes, it's just better
to build your own profiles
within your application, store
them inside of your
application, profile, meaning
that this user is a member of
a particular role and roles
that are checked to see if
they can do different
functions.
Why delegation?
Let's talk a little bit about
a story of the history of
delegation.
A calendaring application is a
very good example of where we
had the boss that delegated
coordinating their
schedule to an admin.
At first, the boss provided the
username and password so
the admin could just
log in as the user.
But that was unsecure.
Companies then started
programming in this delegation
concept into their application
so the boss could add the
admin as a delegate.
But in the world where we have
a bunch of different services
all over the internet, it
becomes more complicated
because now, it's not just one
application you're working
with and different providers.
And applications need to access
Google Calendar data.
A very bad practice began to
store the username and
passwords inside of your
application so it could use
that username and password
to log into Google and
then get the data.
But there's some pretty big
security flaws in here.
Mainly, if your application gets
compromised, then your
usernames and passwords
are lost.
And they have to then
be changed.
And that's when people
created OAuth and
the delegation mechanism.
What this allows you to do is
inside of your app or inside
of Google, you can say that
I want to access a
small subset of data.
So give me a key that only
works to unlock that
small set of data.
And this key is associated
with the user.
But it's not the same thing
as a user and password.
This key then can only
be used just to
unlock that data scope.
It's much more secure.
If your app gets compromised,
all they can do is use those
keys to access the data.
And you can programmatically
revoke those.
And users don't actually
have to change their
username and password.
It's a much better
story overall.
And that's really the
gist of delegation.
You can also allow third party
access to your application
using this as well.
The one difference is, unlike
when you're accessing data on,
for example, Google Calendar,
you can scope it down just to
a small subset of data.
It's an all or nothing
for your application.
So you can't control a subset of
data in my application that
I want to expose.
It's here, my application,
that I want to expose.
And then, it would generate that
token for them that you
could present to a third party
application that they could
then use to pull up access
to your application.
The challenge is OAuth is not
that easy to figure out the
first time you do it.
And there are different
parties involved.
In fact, we actually have a
whole playground that we've
devoted just to OAuth where you
can go through all of our
APIs and authorize
an application.
You can actually step through
each step of the authorization
process here in the
OAuth playground.
So it's a very good tool.
To find it, just go into
developers.google.com.
It's called the Google
OAuth Playground.
One of OAuth's biggest
benefits is its
scoped access to data.
What this means is that you have
a bunch of different keys
that correspond to that scoped
access for a user.
And in this case, I have the
boss and the user, too, that
both have access to, in this
case, a token that's used by
the administrative assistant
calendaring program.
And they're all independent.
So you can revoke them
at any time.
In this case, I have a boss
and the user who both have
access to a token that is used
by the administrative
assistant's calendaring
program.
And they're all independent.
So you can revoke them
at any time.
In this case, if you revoke the
boss's access from that
user, that token for that user
using it then no longer works
for the user.
And the boss doesn't have to
go change their password.
So the very first time that you,
as a developer, are going
to ask a user for that token,
there are a bunch of steps
that go on.
I'm going to try to cover them
and talk about what's created
on Google's infrastructure and
how that interacts with your
application.
The first step is a user asks
the application for something
for it to do for them.
Let's say that that pulls
up my calendar.
Pull up my Google Docs,
pull up my Tweet feed,
whatever it could be.
You have to talk to the
application server.
In this case, I'll use
Google as an example.
The authorization server then
returns a redirect to your
application that you give to
the user that directs the
browser to Google's
authorization server.
It says, here's the request
that I want.
Or I want to allow this
application to access my data.
And it will list clearly what
they want to access.
If the user clicks on "I accept
this access request,"
then Google creates a one-time
code that corresponds to this
access request.
It then sends that one-time
code to the user.
You don't have to understand the
exact characters, but this
is roughly what it looks
like on the right side.
That one-time code is sent
to the user's browser.
As a redirect, I get sent back
to your application.
You use that one-time code as
a call-back to Google's
authorization service as,
here's my one-time code.
Can I access an API now?
In exchange, Google will delete
that one-time code and
create a refresh token
and an access token.
The refresh token is important
because in this case, we're
asking for offline access.
The access token is returned.
You want to store both the
access token and the refresh
token in your application.
The refresh token is something
you can use in the future.
The access token is only
good for about an hour.
It will actually have
an expiration.
But you could take that access
token and either put it as a
header or just append it
to the core string if
that API allows it.
And so every time you make a
call to that API, you include
that access token.
Google verifies that
access token.
And if it is still valid, it
will then return the data to
your application.
So now, all subsequent requests
include that access token.
If the access token is no longer
valid, you have to use
the refresh token to get
a new access token.
Let's say your application did
have that refresh token.
Then what happens the next
time you access that API?
Well, it's pretty simple.
Your application has
that refresh token.
It gives it to Google.
Google looks it up to make
sure it's still valid.
If it is, then it will generate
a brand new access
token, send that back
to your application.
Then, your application can use
that token over and over again
until it's no longer
valid again.
The tricky part is that
at any time, that
access token could fail.
And so you have to program into
your application handling
that error.
It may just be that
it's expired.
And if you have a refresh
token, you'd try it.
But the refresh token
could fail.
And if that happens, you have
to redirect to the user, if
they're logged in to the
application again, to do the
authorization.
If that fails, then you know the
user actually revoked the
token and clicked Deny on that
button when it has prompted
them for access.
So you have to handle
for those cases.
So I talked about exposing your
application through OAuth.
OAuth 2.0 is a standard
out there used by a
lot of other providers.
But the API is considered
somewhat experimental.
You can use it fairly easily,
certainly a lot easier than
programming it yourself.
Keeping track of all those
tokens and the access keys
isn't actually that
easy, however.
So Google does a lot
of that for you.
You can simply say, I want
someone to have a
key for this scope.
It will prompt the user for that
axis just like we prompt
for our own APIs.
And then, it will give the third
party application that
token that will work
for that code.
Then, they'll exchange for the
access token, et cetera.
So it's not just Google
invented, just well supported.
So we have a vested
interest in it.
I encourage you to read more
online at developers.googl
e.com/appengine.
Some of the best practices is
that earlier incarnations of
OAuth have you, as a developer,
do cryptography
inside your application.
But the latest version is
just that access key.
And that's as good as your
using a password.
And that's being sent
over as a header
or as a query parameter.
So make sure you
do it over SSL.
Otherwise, if someone sniffs
that connection, then you can
see that user token for as
long as it's good for.
And if they sniff the connection
that used the
refresh token, well, then they
have the refresh token.
So be very careful in how you
handle that refresh token and
the access token and what
connections you use to the
different authorization
services.
Request the smallest scope
needed possible.
If you don't need Google Docs
access, don't ask for it.
Otherwise, user gets this long
list of things you're
requesting access to when all
you need, maybe, was calendar.
It's going to be simpler and
easier for the user to
understand what's happening.
Request that refresh token
only if you need it.
Again, if your application
doesn't need access offline,
then having that refresh token
really buys you nothing
because you could still
go through that dance.
They call it the OAuth dance.
But that handshake with the
client to get a new access
token won't prompt them for
access if they previously
authorized that application.
So you can effectively
do the same thing.
But if you had a refresh token,
then you could increase
your risk of being compromised
and having a data file that
can be used to access
other users' data.
Plus, the prompt screen gives
them more warning.
Store that refresh
token securely.
We encourage you to explore
further additional useful
resources in these documents,
tools such as OAuth
Playground, and articles.